continuing on my series looking at some
university exams today I'm going to look
at a computer science course so this is
a real exam with solutions from Cornell
University and it was uploaded to their
website so the first link in the
description will be a link to download
this exam and you can read through it at
your own pace it's an introduction to
computer science so it's going to cover
sort of some basic things like what is a
programming language some style and
structure and then getting into some
more basic algorithms and data
structures and these are gonna lay a
ground bass or a theory to write better
code it can be the difference between
good and bad code or code that's fast to
run and code that takes ages so it's
kind of algorithms that keep you using
the best practices so you can you can
write code that's efficient that's the
difference between some of these theory
courses and computer science that you'll
see and just trying to learn a language
straight up without a bit more of this
theory is that yeah it helps you write
better code so this is an introductory
course like I said which means that for
someone who's coming in to the study
having already a bit of computer science
knowledge they might find it a breeze
and that was what I saw happening when I
took a course like this is that some
people definitely found it easier than
others they found it easier than the
people that hadn't had any experience in
the topic but it should be manageable
for anyone if they pay attention in
class and give it their best shot so
let's have a look at what you'd be
expected to do in this exam we've got
nine questions to do in two and a half
hours the first question deals with Big
O notation which talks about how costly
a certain algorithm is to implement it
gives an upper bound or a worst case
scenario of the growth rate of a certain
function depending on how much data
you're dealing with should be a
reasonably straight
odd question to pick out how costly some
of these certain actions are in this
question we are given some functions in
code and we're asked to tell what the
output is going to be there's kind of
only a few options on what can be
returned so it's just a matter of making
sure we know how to read this language
you wouldn't have to worry about
learning a whole bunch of languages
usually the language you'd see in an
exam for a course like this is going to
be what you've been learning throughout
the course and what you've been using so
these two should be reasonably
straightforward as long as you read the
questions really carefully in this
question we're looking at an algorithm
sisyphic read Dijkstra's algorithm which
concerns trying to find the shortest
path between a bunch of nodes so it's
sort of a question of if you're trying
to drop off a bunch of people at their
houses what's going to be a good path to
take to drop off those people so in the
question which is this section you sort
of asked to show how you're going to
implement this algorithm and how you're
going to make updates to it and then
everything in the box is kind of an
expected solution here obviously this is
the model solution so demonstrating an
understanding that you'd have a plan of
implementing this algorithm you should
do all right then on the next page I
think these should be reasonably simple
as well if you've paid attention during
class but you're being asked questions
about spanning trees so these are
algorithms that connect a bunch of dots
so connecting a bunch of trees in a
forest let's say the least possible
amount of edges between the trees some
of these questions are quite basic
because the purpose of this exam is not
for you to show that you can write
complex code or or long and involved
work what you're trying to do is just
that you've understood the basic
concepts that have gone on in class
you're going to be tested on your
ability to write more complex code in
course but that's going to come through
things like assignments weekly homework
something like that where you can
actually have a lot more time to think
and implement things the way you want to
and actually like get out a lot of code
and work on it for a long time an exam
is not that time an exam has a different
purpose it's not for you to show off
your code it's just for you to show yes
you've you've understood some of these
basic ideas that your lecturer is trying
to communicate to you that's why some of
these exams might look easy
I don't think that'd be the hardest part
of the course I think in computer
science the hardest part of the course
is doing those assignments which can be
sometimes quite long and quite a lot of
lines of coding then we're moving on to
some data structures so these are ways
that you would store data in an
efficient manner this particular
question is about something called a
hash table so you've essentially got
here eight buckets that you can put data
into and in this case data is some
numbers and there's a few ways that
these hash tables can work say you're
putting numbers into each bucket for
some assignment process and this
question here is asking you to show the
difference between what happens if
you're trying to put two numbers into
the same box in a you deal with that by
chaining so you just sort of append the
second number onto the end of the first
one and then B you deal with that by
linear probing so if one box is full you
move on to the next box and keep looking
for boxes until you find one that's
empty and place their number in there so
different ways to deal with the storing
data in a table
then we've got a bunch of true/false
questions some relating specifically to
what would have been the programming
language used in this course which looks
like it was Java and then a few more
questions about algorithms and a few
statements you've got another big
o-notation down the bottom one really
useful thing in computer science is
something called a binary tree and
that's what some of these questions are
all about a binary tree is something
where you have say a parent node and
then you can have children coming off of
that parent node so you can have one two
or three children and those are going to
be related in some way and these binary
trees are a way to organize data so that
you can look up values say the maximum
or a minimum value in a set of data
they're quite efficient at doing that so
we've got a bunch of questions here
again they're reasonably simple you're
not being asked to write a bunch of code
you're just being asked to understand
what something like this can help you do
so just a few questions about maybe
manipulating these or understanding them
this is a question where you are
actually asked to write a bit of code as
your answer and might be a little bit
daunting I guess but it's reasonably
simple function compared to what you've
probably done during the assignments so
it shouldn't be too bad this is a
written exam so some people would find
it weird to be writing code down with a
pen and paper rather than typing it
you've just got to be meet with your
notation but usually it's kind of good
actually to to write code in an exam in
the sense because if you do forget
something like a semicolon your lecture
is probably going to be a bit more
lenient because they understood what you
meant to do then a computer who will
just completely reject your answer so I
guess it has a benefit in that way my
uni where I did computer science an
undergrad we're phasing to not use paper
exams at all and to do it all online on
the
Peter so in that sense you would have to
pay more attention to making sure the
code you write in an exam is correct but
there's benefits to both so here yeah we
just have a few more questions about the
structure of binary trees and then a
final question which was maybe one of
the most mathematical in here it's a
proof by induction and again it relates
to binary trees so it again relates to
the idea of efficiently dealing with
data how to sort through it how to store
it and just how to write good code I
hope that wasn't scary and I hope it
didn't look too easy either but yeah
it's an introductory computer science
course there's definitely a lot more
advanced things you can do with this
hopefully it was a good snippet at what
you can expect thanks for watching